All right.
We're one day closer to launch.
And we've got tons of
traffic on the site.
Things are looking pretty great.
>> Excellent,
well I just booked my trip to Hawaii.
With the launch so close,
I'm sure nothing could go wrong.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah.
That's funny.
>> What?
>> It's probably nothing.
I don't know, but
take look at the data structure.
I must have not deleted one
of my test shopping lists.
Hm, these are data seems to
have a couple of fields that
I don't really remember
putting in there.
And some of these emails
look a little bit off.
Man, I must be really out of it.
It should be easy that to fix though.
>> What if while you're fixing that,
you also future-proofed your data by
creating Firebase security rules?
This would help both make sure you don't
accidentally introduce anything to your
data structure you didn't mean to, and
protect your app against those
with malicious intentions.
>> Well, it does look like we have
a little bit more time before lunch.
Hey, developer, are you still with us?
Maybe we could talk a little
bit about security.